oh look at this this is a good one some
suggest that parker's powers include the
male spider's ability to hypnotize
females stop come on yes my spider lord
what's up everyone carlos here the wait
for the official spiderman no way home
trailer has been
weird for months now whenever marvel
dropped something online there'd be a
group of people that were like yeah but
where's the spider-man trailer then
another group of people would remind
that group of people that it's not
marvel dropping the trailer it's
actually a sony and then there are
people who are like you know what forget
it i'm just gonna make my own trailer
and then when we finally got official
trailer footage that was leaked another
group of people that sony were like
okay here's the trailer now in case you
were wondering no spider-man star tom
holland did not leak anything in fact
tom did a little bit of trolling himself
sharing you aren't ready to his
instagram stories after news of that
leaked trailer and for those of you who
waited to watch the official version the
spider-man no way home twitter wants to
congratulate you writing shout out to
the real ones for watching the trailer
for the first time right now
shout out does not apply to me now if
you haven't seen the official trailer or
the leaked version and you're probably
just waking up so good morning but go
watch the trailer okay because spoilers
and if you have watched it a bunch of
times all the versions well
let's dig in
we just like stay up here all day it is
so crazy down there
that's right folks spiderman is in fact
peter parker so if you saw spiderman far
from home you know the deal here
mysterio framed spiderman for his own
death and revealed that he's actually a
kid named peter parker news that was
delivered by notorious spider-man hater
jay jonah jameson so the world at least
new york apparently believes this and
now pete along with his family and
friends are in trouble the trailer shows
us various scenes of the public hating
them and the authorities going after
them even ant-may's boyfriend happy
hogan gets a cameo here and speaking of
cameos unless happy is your fav mcu
character which if he is amazing
that is probably far from the most
exciting one in this trailer i'm sorry
to bother you sir please we're safe to
have the universe together i think we're
beyond you calling me sir okay
stephen
that feels weird but i'll allow it
there's of course doctor strange which
we'll get to in a minute but the real
conversation centers around the teases
of spider-man's rogues gallery hopping
universes into this one the big
lightning flashes surely mean electro
that's probably a given the biggest
jaw-dropping moment the pumpkin bomb
signaling green goblin's return with an
unmistakable willem to fall laugh
and we already knew alfred molina would
be back as doc ock because well he told
us so in an interview with variety where
he literally called it the worst kept
secret in hollywood which you know i
don't care it's super cool to see him
back
hello peter
[Music]
and he looks great by the way now this
moment however has everyone talking
this dark scene appears to be the lizard
from 2012's the amazing spider-man but
some folks out there are certain that
it's actually venom
now be careful what you wish for given
that the villains are returning from
past spider-man movies it might not be
the venom you're expecting
i mean i don't actually think that's
gonna happen but
to be kind of amazing and hilarious in
its own way right
aside from the villains we also have
this shot of a stack of papers being
slammed down by someone who people are
insisting is charlie cox as matt murdock
frankly it makes sense and i want to
believe it so shout out to the internet
super sleuths out there getting all my
hopes up the entire world is about to
forget the peter parker spider-man wait
everyone
okay some people still know that's not
how the spell works
so the potential cameos have people all
riled up but what about the story it's
hard to piece together with what the
trailer gives us we know most of the mcu
properties are playing in the multiverse
right now and it's surely the reason all
these different villains are showing up
if i have one little issue and trust me
i know we're not going on a lot here so
this could change
that doctor strange would mess up this
spell because peter's talking too much
and we've seen this man in battle versus
thousands of enemy aliens i feel like he
has more focus than this
anyway what did you all think of the
trailer we did not get confirmation of
toby mugay or andrew garfield returning
as their spider-man we did get doc
saying hello peter i'm pretty sure he's
not talking to tom holland give us your
reaction to the trailer below what do
you think is the next thing we'll hear
about spider-man no way home and who's
on your wish list of cameos thanks for
watching everyone see you next time
you